bonsoir gérard vespière merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte froid
les talibans ont donc annoncé l'homme
fort de leur nouveau gouvernement il
s'agit de mohammad hassan plutôt méconnu
mais à ses côtés il y à abdul ghani
baradar l'un des co fondateurs du
mouvement islamiste il ya également le
fils du mollah omar ou le fils du jalal
oudina cagnes est en fait du neuf avec
du vieux
ah oui il ya pas mal de cela
effectivement donc le nom complet à
mohammad hassan à qund à qui va être le
nouveau chef de gouvernement et est
plutôt d'un profil religieux n'est ce
pas il a suivi pendant de très
nombreuses années le leader actuel des
taliban à accous zarrad donc voilà c'est
lui qui l'a nommé on retrouve un petit
peu le système et la philosophie
iraniennes d'un leader religieux donc le
leader des talibans qu'ils nomment
désigne dans le cadre de lire en star
avec une élection bien l'élection sert
pas à grand chose faut être quand même
clairvoyant donc là il s'agit de la
nomination plus tôt d'un religieux et
seconde est effectivement par baradar
qui lui est un homme politique
d'expérience il a été déjà vice premier
ministre de 1996 à 2001 il était en
charge des affaires étrangères il était
au qatar à doha pour la négociation avec
les états unis donc voilà une
affiliation religieuse avec autour bien
des accointances et des capacités
politiques avec baradar pourquoi avoir
attendu aujourd'hui pour annoncer à tous
ses membres de ce gouvernement à cause
du panjshir parce que les talibans
disent contrôler la vallée alors que le
frère du défunt commandant massoud a dit
le contraire
cet après midi qui croient sincèrement
c'est à une guerre de communiqués je
pense que la situation n'est pas aussi
facile pour la résistance dans le ponde
chirac est là elle a cru à le fils de
massoud n'est pas le commandant massoud
sauf à lui manquer de respect mais voilà
il son père avait une expérience
militaire que lui n'a pas je pense que
si la détermination des équipes sur
place n'était pas aussi évidente il y
avait un co président du front national
de résistance qui était un politique qui
était en négociations avec les talibans
donc on était dans une situation un
petit peu je dirais un bicéphale
la première chose c'est que il a fallu
trois semaines à pour que ce
gouvernement où ce gouvernement
intermédiaires dont on ne sait pas très
bien si les choses vont rester là
comment ce gouvernement va être
augmentée de quelle façon dans quel
délai donc il a fallu trois semaines je
pense que les talibans étaient un peu
surpris aussi de la rapidité de leur
avancée a donc il y a beaucoup de
négociations car à l'évidence
l'afghanistan qu'ils trouvent maintenant
en 2021 est très très loin de
l'afghanistan de 1996
c'est à dire
c'est à dire que en 96 aviez un pays de
2 17 millions d'habitants 17 millions
d'habitants maintenant vous avez 37
millions d'habitants vous avez
pratiquement 20% de la population à qui
habitent dans des villes alors que
l'afghanistan était un pays hautement
rural dont vous avez à degré
d'urbanisation
1° donc d'accoutumance de contact avec
le monde occidental depuis 20 ans on le
voit avec les manifestations des femmes
on le voit avec cette demande de liberté
de pouvoir faire le métier qu'on veut de
pouvoir se former que l'on veut donc on
en a aussi un afghanistan plus riches
n'est ce pas le pib était multipliée par
habitant a été multiplié par trois la
durée de vie moyenne a augmenté de 9 ans
donc il y à un nouvel afghanistan et les
talibans vont devoir éminemment en tenir
compte il y aura beaucoup plus de
demandes de la population d'un point de
vue économique et social qu'il n'y a eu
en 96 on sortait d'un régime très
autoritaire a donc avec un parti
communiste avec l'invasion soviétique
quelques années plus tôt donc voilà on
est là dans une arrivée les talibans
après 20 ans une forme de liberté tous
les cas
il ya une information qui vient de
tomber deux morts et huit blessés dans
une manifestation anti taliban à haïr at
indique la spl afp un médecin local sous
couvert d'anonymat que ça augure des
choses un peu compliquées pour le
gouvernement taliban dans les jours les
semaines à venir
voilà c'est ce que je commençais à
l'essai en temps n'est-ce pas
l'afghanistan ne sachant qu'il avait
aussi une manifestation de femmes ans
aujourd'hui à kaboul 1 absolument il y
en a eu aussi à erat donc il y en a eu à
mazars et chalets donc voilà le le nord
commencerait-il à bouger ce n'est pas
impossible même si les seigneurs de la
guerre
cannes deux hommes se sont repliés ont
laissé les talibans arriver mais il y à
une insatisfaction ils disent avoir une
insatisfaction
social économie d'une population qui a
été ajoutée à un niveau de vie n'est ce
pas voilà qui a augmenté et il va avoir
des exigences donc
le frein aux libertés un combat
le secrétaire d'état français aux
affaires européennes clément bonne a
affirmé récemment que pour reconnaître
le gouvernement taliban il fallait avoir
un signe d'ouverture dans leur exécutif
avoir des figures de l'opposition par
exemple ou bien des femmes simples voeux
pieux ou bien ce que ce voeu peut-il
être exaucé encore
d'après vous
alors ça ça va faire partie des grandes
manoeuvres n'est ce pas ah parceque un
afghanistan comme je le soulignais de 37
millions d'habitants a besoin de
beaucoup de ressources extérieures 80 %
du budget de l'état vient de l'extérieur
donc il va lui falloir
faire des deals devra faire des
concessions et ça va être une situation
totalement nouvelle pour le monde
talibans où il va y avoir plusieurs
courants qui vont probablement se
discerner se différencier un courant
très conservateur un colorant réaliste
en eas en bas nous héritons d'une
situation nouvelle donc il faut faire
avec et puis les bains le courant d
entre eux deux ils ont donc eu de cette
situation très unitaire de 96
idéologique radical on les talibans on
va avoir affaire à une réalité à vianne
fort différente en en 2021
dernière question gérard vespière par
rapport aux futurs liens diplomatiques
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre entre le
gouvernement taliban justement y les
principales puissances mondiales etats
unis on a vu anthony blinken encore
aujourd'hui à doha russie avec des
exercices militaires au kirghizstan la
chine également la france la grande
bretagne ou encore l'allemagne
je crois qu'il ya une demande générale
qui ait pas de guerre civile ah parce
que les voisins craignent comme la peste
une guerre civile en afghanistan l'iran
avec déjà huit cent mille réfugiés le
pakistan qui ne veut pas une extension
donc violente des ses propres taliban et
vous avez la chine dont il ya une toute
petite frontière de 75 km mais c'est
avec le sinn kg en espace chinois là où
sont les ouigours la population
musulmane donc les voisins immédiats ne
veulent absolument pas de conflit armé
intérieur pas de guerre civile et c'est
la même situation où la russie bien sûr
qu'ils continuent à avoir des liens
privilégiés avec ses anciennes
républiques à turkménistan ouzbékistan
et autres et puis sa population
musulmane en tchétchénie au daghestan
donc il faut à pour la russie qu'il n'y
ait absolument pas de conflits
intérieurs de guerre civile en
afghanistan parce qu'une guerre civile
exacerbe les passions et va pousser à
des mouvements violents à l'intérieur de
province ou d'états qui ont des
populations musulmanes